[Musique]
l'équipe des décrypteurs a reçu de
nombreux courriels au cours des
dernières semaines à propos de ce
documentaire qui était mise en ligne de
cet avril sur deux chaînes youtube à
ceux ci au quotidien epoch times charles
biskra mais nous sommes plus une voix
quelle crédibilité doit-on accorder à
cette vidéo visionnée à des millions de
reprises et qui cumule une quantité
déconcertante d'affirmations
fracassantes sur l'origine du virus
responsables de l'aco 20 19 je me suis
penché sur ce dossier
allons-y d'abord avec un tour d'horizon
rapide des principales affirmations
contenues dans ce documentaire numéro un
le nouveau coronavirus est le fruit
d'une manipulation humaine en
laboratoire jusqu'à présent l'origine
animale du nouveau coronavirus demeure
l'hypothèse la plus probable
on est parvenu à ce consensus
scientifique grâce au séquençage complet
du génome du virus ce qui a été réalisé
dès la mi janvier pour ensuite être
scrutée à la loupe dans des laboratoires
aux quatre coins du monde
numéro 2 le virus a délibérément été
relâché en dehors du laboratoire de
virologie de wuhan
il faut rappeler que le washington post
révélait récemment que des diplomates
américains basés en chine aurait alerté
washington en 2018 au sujet de mesures
de sécurité est jugé insuffisant dans le
laboratoire de wuhan
mais malgré tout ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est qu'aucune preuve tangible et
vérifier nous indique clairement qu'une
brèche de sécurité de cette ampleur l'un
a été détecté dans la foulée de
l'apparition des tout premiers cas de
kovy 19 dans la province chinoise de
hubei en principe le laboratoire en
question qui relève de l'académie
chinoise des sciences est doté du plus
haut niveau de sécurité niveau p4 qui
est fixé en fonction des normes
internationales
laissons donc les enquêtes se faire
avant de sauter aux conclusions
c'est ce qu'on vous propose un petit mot
maintenant sur un puck times le journal
fondé en 2000 par des américains
d'origine chinoise depuis ses débuts
epoch times est associé au mouvement
falun gong un courant spirituel souvent
qualifié de secte par ses détracteurs le
falun gong a été déclaré hors la loi par
pékin en 1999
le journal epoch times et la chaîne new
tang dynasty d'origine sont donc les
bras médiatique du mouvement
leur mission fondamentale pour fendre la
bête noire des adeptes du falungong
c'est à dire le parti communiste chinois
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là une enquête
approfondie du réseau américain nbc news
dévoile l été dernier les dessous du
virage pro trempe de epoch times aux
alentours de 2016
c'est à partir de ce moment-là qu'est
pop times s est mis à financer des
publicités pour aux trompes sur facebook
et à relayer des thèses associé au
mouvement conspirationnistes américain
que johann n vous pouvez dire
l'intégralité de mon article à ce sujet
sur la page web des décrypteurs
n'hésitez pas à rejoindre notre groupe
facebook
fort de plus de 30 mille membres déjà
jusqu'à présent allez salut
[Musique]